era da un po che mi chiedevate di
portare rocket league solo che stavo
aspettando di avere il compagno giusto
ciccio marino si è proposto l'altro
giorno di fare un paio di partite con me
il risultato è stato questo buona
visione dalle ferite va bene va bene va
bene se cipro ciccio ciccio riccio fato
che gioca mai oggi devo giocare con te e
ti subito perché devo saperlo sai cosa
che io loro mandato libano io ho pagato
per farmi carico dai ci ho fatto anche
il gol
questo è il volo dell'angelo porca vacca
la tolgo mamma mia mi sono caricato
forte ma ed ebbe su rai e scherzavano
tranquilla ragazzi tanto io sono così
attaccante che portiamo questa è bella
batosta contro hamas è diventato più
bravo o quel tocco esco e da che fatta
single è infatti un gol prima ha detto
bene adesso signora la nostra parte
della storia verte in questi complimenti
che mi fai perché io no poi l'imbarazzo
troppo e perde va bene fai schifo ciccio
l'hai mai e poi mai benzina e se benzina
nel partito fortissimo siano esse più
visto è stato bellissimo
va bene ragazzi ragazzi ci sono ci sono
lavezzi cieli spingermi è che io sono un
po e non la prendo
porca vacca certo ci sta bene
ok dai dai
e poi c'è i sei ragazzi bravissimo
ciccio ancora in mezzo ancora 18 katyn
un tocchettino forse non è vero che
questa era una giocata da pietro è di
quelle pervenute loro arrivo io è stato
che la mia ragazzi che ovviamente
parquet casinò era come questa un
biliardo che a zona parla distrugge
tutto vi dedica una canzone vera
vittoria
ok ragazzi queste per poi grazie mi è
piaciuta tantissimo vero ha detto la
parola magica palla magica ed mi sento
mi fa male la mano a scriverlo tg1 di
infliggere di dio ma lo faccio prima
volta la verità bimbominkia si è detto
c'era idiot
a un certo punto infatti bisogna
scrivere forfait forfait anche nello
scrivere dopo adesso si saranno
incazzati neri tentati di sicuro sicuro
di pur se sarah ci avranno la rogna nel
corpo proprio della serie vorranno
segnare così fosse questione di vita o
di morte
bello bello un dono rotello
bello bello bello
meno pessimo fantastico grande vedendoli
mi chiamerà vita ragazzi non lo devi
scrivere bene degli schiavi così adesso
hai capito sicura
quando gli eventi qua david è arrivata
insieme entrare hai hai hai hai hai hai
anche male ma voi ci segnano in 14 16
con tre gol è più forte
e in tutto questo ha segnato 4 a 3 a 12
secondi fanno in tempi stima segnare di
montorio ma tutti mi lasciate
ok bravi bravi ragazzi ci regala la
prima prima vinta la seconda pure va
vinta mai 10 giu la terza basta sincero
non ho mai scappato nei giochi da sempre
sto bravo d'abilità tipo ora tipo
vinco tutto ok bello per te protesta
ritoccarla addirittura qualcuno poi
vabbè dai importa tanto non dietro i
quali si dirà ma non pensava da
sorriderti importa peccato che no non
entrate perché attraverso le male qui
posso giocare ok ma di un millimetro non
l'ho presa ma quanta sfiga incredibile e
creano colpe
siamo due a zero non mente a 0 sopra
vita anzi non mi sono neanche troppo
forti
[Musica]
guardali che cosi massiccio ed è chiuso
vince ahi ahi follo vioni on youtube
vecchio che cosa i need subscriber ok ok
minchia bella lavoro comparativamente
bene la butta in mezzo dai mezzo davide
bravo aspetta ancora in mezzo ciccio
guarino cazzo è un po era poco fortescue
the moment a quanta ansia di una persona
sola l'asm ha prodotto la sanno fare ma
perche da questa barche culo attraversa
bravissimo ci si aspetta paola gli
importava entrava sulla toglieva mamma
mia ragazzi
e allora mi volete male porca eva
ragazzi basta spingermi gol che gol
sotto il sette come mai nei club per
haga tranqui romantici sono io
tirate fortissimo ci sono la nostra di
labro ma quanta cattiveria
3 a 2 così non ci sta
ragazzi stare tranquilli colpo di drago
paura che si è mostrato quindi dobbiamo
andare avanti va a segnare bravo dare
una rapida così davide tutti i dodici si
gioco da ragazzi tocca toccato anche al
grande e butta in mezzo che si chiama
tutti un secondo e non potere attrazione
ma dove c'è stato anche io attenzione
non finisce la partita la giocano
ragazzi ma chiaro un'ora e non finiva
martello ha detto vai da solo può
resistere importavano un po bravo
bellissimo arrivato a caricare però
forse riesce a batterlo mammamia da
quelli utili no non è vero ti tocca
tocca scoperta la porterà che scoperto
scoperta ciccio sei tu che devi stare
alla situazione salva la foto
[Applauso]
allora mi a fornire face dai la terza è
quella giusta raga
la terza è l'ultima data la pasqua io
non riesco non capisco ma come prenderla
sai mamma mia che è il missile gli ho
tirato però non è entrato mi sfotte sky
mi dispiace perché nella parata minchia
di affari 10 gol a sti qua tranquillo e
questa non è verde
da qui grazie
ok ci sono la mancata mancata occhio
occhio che questi segnano da cazzo
davide scritto da vinci cuore a partire
da adesso dai
mammamia lorenzo ragazzo di noi ha fatto
anche lui lo stesso e verso che ho fatto
io infatti ed attenzione adesso si
saranno partner magazine e non messi
meno che qualcuno per loro per loro e la
nostra parte a quella ciccio un'altra
volta di giocare tutti aperti ma
continuano a dover ammettere che succeda
abbiamo forti riscontri e colore insomma
va bene gli score di che colore 6 è il
mondo che traversa ok tirateci a
rimanere un po dietro perché sono questi
minchia no lo vedo bene 3500 salvataggio
di consegnare il mio signore che lo
meritiamo noi questa partita
basta per forza per forza dopo un
peccato solo non assegniamo noi ragazzo
bella ciccio chiuso contratti val
d'orcia parabile bravo davide c6 tempi
supplementari chi segna vince 1 a 1 ma
perche mi devono spingere a chi tocca
tocca solo non toccava potrà essere gol
a caso ho detto che la casa non è vero
nella vita del mondo dell'universo di
giuda morto davanti alla grande davanti
qualcuno si meraviglia tira tira non è
vero che la cittadina per qualcosa le 6
cp perché lo brucio brucio mamma mi ha
causato 8 mi sono caricato forte partirà
un'attenzione non la tolgo non la tolgo
[Risate]
guarda se vincevamo questa facciamo
schifo è veramente hanno tirato un
milione di volte a garantire una volta
ed è adatta meglio abbiamo perso da
l'abbiamo vinta una però ci eravamo
andati vicino in tutte quante quindi non
così male dai quindi ragazzi spero che
video vi sia piaciuto cosa mi piace
anche marito cerca di iscrizione
fischiatemi e noi ci vediamo al prossimo
da ragazzi
[Musica]